[Music]
welcome to london a city steeped in
history and known for its iconic
landmarks
[Music]
british cuisine might not be world round
but
the city is full of great food that
extends way beyond its classic fish and
chips
first up an american classic with an
indian twist a londoner's favorite
[Music]
originally i came up with this idea when
i was only about 14 years old i used to
make them from my friends barbecues
culturally is a mishmash you can only
find this in london my name's alec i'm
from babaji's and we are in the
wonderful camden market sun's beating
down it's a wonderful day
the naga delhi double burger is made
with two fresh spiced lamb patties
served on a brioche naan style bun
between the two lamp patties is a crispy
onion bhaji on top of that we've got our
spiced naga deli double sauce it's made
with a naga chili pickle to give that
really authentic indian taste you'll get
sharp sweet spicy and then that lovely
juicy lamb on top
it's a big old burger you've got to be
hungry you have to try one mate
next up head to the windy streets of
soho and check out this small hole in
the wall serving up a traditional
chinese breakfast dish
i am proud to have brought an evolved
version of jam being to london
my name is seth
he and i am a co-founder of pleasant
ladies we are located in soho on greek
street pleasant ladies specialize in
jian bing some people call it a chinese
burrito like a savory chinese crepe
after we spread the batter on the hot
plate we then crack an egg on top spread
it out
flip it brush a house made sweet
fermented bean sauce chili oil a herb
salad after that it's your choice of
meat our house pickle and then your
chinese cracker and then rolled it up
and then you've got all your springiness
the chewiness the freshness and the
crispiness
i think that it's everybody's food
tucked away in a south london market is
a chip shop that isn't always playing by
the rules
i would say these are not traditional
chips but are a mix of different
cultures in one plate my name is marco
our shop is poptata and we are located
in tutti market in southwest london
one of our signature dishes is
definitely the guaca fries double cooked
fresh and cut chips
with the herbal seasoning a touch of
garlic
grill aluminum cheese from greece a
little bit of british cheddar mature
cheddar and there's mesh avocado fresh
both from the market so it's very
interesting because you got different
textures and different flavors obviously
the chips are crunchy and the cheese
with the heat of the fries of the chips
is melting on top
and then you've got the tanginess of the
sauce at the end so it's kind of windy
usually chips are served as a side but
what we try to do is for us to have the
chips as a main character so they're not
the side anymore
back towards the city center you'll find
a brazilian classic using an ingredient
we've never seen before
this is a traditional northeast
brazilian thing but it started with the
amazonia native tribes
my name is gustavo our shop is called
bay germany and is located at old
spitter fields market shoreditch london
this is beijou the closest thing would
be a flatbread in order to make it we
have to add a couple of spoons of
tapioca flour put on a hot pan once the
bottom is cooked you just put upside
down and it starts filling up to taste
inside the mushroom bijami there is
grated cheddar
mushroom with garlic and parsley
tomatoes red onions some chili goat
cheese
and spinach
it's slightly different than normal
bread because it is made purely of
starches so it's going to have a chewy
consistency
outside we leave it crispy our own way
it tastes incredible
[Music]
and finally for a twist on a traditional
aripa there's only one place we
recommend for this one
it's this spot
[Music]
in colombia we moda 33 type of arepa so
i found that mine has to be different i
have to get one step forward and that's
what i did my name is patricio mercado
my shop is mulatta and we are in
paddington in london the dish that i
created is called mulatta
mulata means is a mixed race
and the reason why i use my name is to
make me feel more proud where i come
from
to make the mulatta we open the kanban
we put guacamole chicken with the red
kidney beans a bit of cheese we put it
back in the griddle
melt the cheese and wrap it with the
cheese melted and we finished with the
torch of guacamole many people just put
the fresh cheese i use the cheese we
seal it and then it's a different thing
i just try to just recreate something
that will bring the roots of home so
it's something born here in london but
with the essence from colombian
traditions
you